hey guys I going happy whatever today is
when you're watching this I was thinking
about what video to do today and I
looked out of my outfit that I happened
to be wearing you guys are watching my
video that's for a while you know that
I'm obsessed with camo and I said today
I was going to do a nice little camo eye
color for you this is something that you
can wear when you go hunting I don't
really know what ever else you would
wear this may be the prom bonus points
to anybody who wears a Kambo prom dress
and there's a nice little camo eye color
i were to go to prom this is what I
would do
I'm not doing wrong first steps first I
would put on some moisturizer I like to
be moisturized
let's get these eyes nice and primed up
you know just to give something this
nice camel color to stick to green brown
brown will green so I'm making kind of
just a little tea shape with this Brown
I just don't have a nice little base
24-hour pillar tattoo you ain't even
gonna be able to see me emotional it
looks just terrible oh it's beautiful
that looks good let's do the other eye I
want my date to love my look I want him
to be like you're so sexy I'd buy you a
drink but you're not old enough you're
not old enough to drink when you are
going to prom let's just move on and add
a little bit of a darker green here push
by a tree puts more of us on the outer
bit I think it's looking great
our brows as the Newmark a take me home
tonight I think the eyes are pretty much
done this a little just nice little
square may look a little orange because
I wanted to have a pan and because I
wanted to look a little bit like a tree
tree bark Luffy like a prom queen or
twin - Dubrow let make my brows as spiky
as possible because I want them to look
like tree branches lime this bottom
mmm-hmm yeah nice little brown color for
the lips is more of a camel look I don't
want to do a bright pink blush so I'm
just going to do some bronzer go wild
this is prom or hunting mascara to
really just set these eyes just let them
open to set them alive I plan on getting
real crazy a prom but I don't want to
have to be messing with my lashes I said
now I'm gonna get my dress on oh it
looks so pretty
alright guys that's it for my camo prom
hunting look hope you guys enjoyed it
thank you to francesca for my birthday
gift of this amazing dress I can't wait
to actually wear this one day it's gonna
be amazing thanks for watching don't
forget to click like don't forget to
subscribe and I'll see you guys in my
next video and if you have any other
ideas for some makeup looks leave me
some comments easy as that I'll see you
guys later I